[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is our friend and
OG youtuber the one and only
Kassem G Kassim started his channel
which currently says that 2.6 million
subscribers and 400 million views way
back in 2006 he's one of the cofounders
of the now Disney owned maker studios
and he's honed his signature sharp
sarcastic comedic tone via his popular
series California on now you've probably
seen it where you can have hilarious
moments from impromptu conversations on
the streets of Venice Beach and
elsewhere including various conventions
first of all you want to do this shirts
on or off you always have the option
tell me about your personal life are you
single taken no I don't care about in
New York the nice guy you have to be
because you're not attractive enough to
be a bad guy just a regular man I'm just
a regular guy with no job you're not
related to Carmen Sandiego in any way
nobody's in San Diego that I know you
want to kiss my head what year did we
sign up
you said can you say that again but just
even more stupid do you get naked at any
point in this biscuit we talked with
Kasim about his participation in the
grueling desert race the Baja 1000 he's
moving to the US is a little kid and
trying to fit in how he recently
connected with his middle-eastern roots
and his candid thoughts on his legendary
youtube series including California on
going deep and asked Kasim we also
talked about what he's been up to lately
not a lot of stuff coming out on his
YouTube channel until very recently his
latest project about Bigfoot yeah it's a
half hour special on his YouTube channel
we've watched it since having the
conversation I highly recommend it you
should check it out on his channel it's
called California on sasquatch a not
Finding Bigfoot special so we think you
guys will enjoy our conversation with
Cassim but first we want to mention our
sponsor EF College Break they make
travel easy affordable and even more fun
for anyone 18 to 28 college not required
yet this is really cool you're young you
should travel this and experience global
experiences while skipping around
foreign destinations experience those
experiences analyze the fact is it can
be logistically difficult to line all
this up you can spend hours searching
the internet for flights and hotels and
coordinating transportation between
cities with sites and getting tickets
for sites in advance and dealing with
closures and cancellations and delays or
you could let EF college break do all
that for you they take care of booking
flights lodging transportation when
you're there site an event coordination
and they provide you with a tour
director who is a local expert that
comes in handy because you go to a place
and you have no idea what most moves to
do
we're am I supposed to go would they
take care of that they've built group
trips across six continents with
everything and that's not I'm talking
about the continents I'm not talking
about whether you're incontinent or not
no has nothing to do with continents
theirs knows this continent no
discrimination on that front you can
poop in your pants all you want while
traveling it doesn't matter they'll take
everywhere from trekking to Machu Picchu
cruising the Greek Isles and immersing
yourself in Germany's Oktoberfest and
almost half of all college break
travelers sign up solo
so even if you sign up by yourself you
will not be alone on your trip make some
friends yeah they call it social travel
because you get to meet new people make
lifelong friends by experiencing the
world together bottom line you might
fall in love that's what happens usually
not well I mean it when you people
travel together it's not about travel
can't help but think that you know
seventeen days with somebody you never
know what'll happen it's not about that
that's just that's only from us that's
not from EF College break that's just
from not even from us what address from
me what about the poop in your pants
part is that from you or that's just for
me I take responsibility for both of
those diversions bottom line it doesn't
have to be intimidating to plan a trip
outside of the country the world is out
there waiting to be explored people go
for it then Instagram some pics to us so
we can experience it vicariously through
you because we are no longer 18 to 20
we're not but we would do this if we
could and we're gonna hook you up with
an extra $100 off your next adventure by
going to our special URL EF College
break.com slash rhett and Link I'm at
the site right now and there's a
highlights of Japan and China trip that
covers 17 days pretty awesome Kyoto
Osaka Tokyo this sounds like a great way
to fill up that where I've been at the
people used to have on their Facebook
well I remember that when they would
brag about how well-traveled they are
well if you want to be one of those
people you should do this for $100 off
go to EF college break comm slash rhett
and Link now on to the biscuit
I thought for my money there was nothing
better than the the micro built series
you guys did I don't know if that's what
you call it that way yeah those guys
aren't we don't want to talk about but I
thought those for my money on the
internet were as good of a of just
content entertainment as you could watch
and I was in France for some fancy thing
doing like one of those you guys go to
those upfront things where you have to
talk about your stuff yeah we went to
one we've been to one in France okay
yeah the one maybe you were at or the
year before but they asked me to come up
to the stage and talk about like just
YouTube videos that I liked okay and I
you know I had some like sketchy and
yeah they're all my own and then the
last one was and I'm specifically save
it for last because it always gets the
most last was the red house furniture
thing and I was just like I think these
guys do the best job of creating
something and at the same time it gives
back to a local business and it's like
not harmful pranky stuff mmm it's just
right it's just really good and I was
always bummed to that there wasn't more
well I appreciate that you know and I'll
go ahead and jump into this I think that
jump into it like you um it means a lot
coming from you because we've always
respected you as a comedian there's
there's lots of people on YouTube who
might call themselves comedians but
they're the people just came up as
youtubers who know I hear what you're
saying I mean but I'm just like I don't
find it funny
and honestly I when it comes to what's
the funniest thing we've ever done
I would easily put our local commercials
at the top of the list and red house up
there because I don't I don't know
exactly why maybe it's because it's it's
separated from us so I can appreciate it
whereas I'm very self-conscious of the
stuff we try to do and plus the stuff we
do is it's for a wider audience and for
something to really resonate with a
comedian that you respect it has to be
something that's very specific yeah
mm-hmm so you know I appreciate that I
think there's kind of this chip on our
shoulder that we we you know what do
what do the comedian's that we respect
of what we do because a lot of it is
that is up I think really big issue for
just youtubers or people that make
online content yeah and and there's that
constant struggle of validation like I
want somebody who's not a youtuber to
like it
or somebody who's like you know a guy
was in movies ten years ago to like you
know just you you feel like you need
that outside validation when you know
you got there because of the YouTube
community well if you want to be a
comedian you want the respect of
comedians not just commenters right I've
struggled that persona in a year I mean
it's like now I think I'm a little older
than when we all started right then
we're a little bit more mature about it
but there was always that is this funny
just because like it's it's just like I
think a thirteen-year-old might think
it's funny or is it funny because I
think it's yeah because it doesn't
necessarily translate that what is
actually funny as what rises to the top
off yeah YouTube I mean when we think
about what what we're doing I mean the
thing that makes us the most amused is
definitely the local commercials but we
don't do them anymore I know it's like a
you have to explain to me why because I
don't really know why because they like
they had to work in spite of us like
people had to believe that they were
real
and the more we associated them with us
the worse they would do because people
want to believe that Chuck testa made
his own commercial right that the guys
at red house big head and 10-gauge
conceptualized that commercial well the
commercial always has to go has to
basically break before they find out
that we're behind it yeah but to me
that's what I like like I like you guys
you're being you're like thing and then
you still use the people that are I mean
the red house one is like it's not like
you guys are in there saying all those
things black and white you know them do
everything like force when people find
out that we're behind it so like now
when we if we take a little commercial
and put it on like the rhett and Link
channel yeah then it's immediately the
people who are there waiting for the
next music video or you know whatever we
haven't done a lot on that channel a
while but when that happens again
they're not expecting another local
commercial they're like what is what is
this yeah you know and so I mean it
doesn't guys got to make more videos
yeah the way we are
okay you guys slack so that's you know
that's the that's the challenge it's
like how much do you listen to yeah
I it's the same things for you I mean
yeah I listen to just myself it seems no
no no I'm look at ask Qasim the show
that you know we you know once once you
went full body on green-screen yeah we
were like that no we were like this no
and this is it this is my favorite thing
I love that show and watch the evolution
of that show of like starting as a as a
blog that a lot of people were doing at
the time right then all of a sudden oh
no he's on a green screen no he's he's
in a cowboy shot on the green screen -
yeah oh you know if you would just back
up just a little bit I know I think if
if you would have told me you know cuz
it's been I don't know three to three
years since I've we made the last
episode of that show and for anyone that
doesn't know it's a show it was just
like you know how youtubers have the I'm
gonna respond to comments show you know
everyone has their own version of that
and I decided to do my version of it and
it started like you said just in my
bedroom and just putting but it became
making fun of that genre totally and
then it became I know I'm cutting you
off but in my mind it became you're just
like f that genre I'm just gonna this is
how I'm gonna be funny
and I'm just gonna make I'm not along
even making fun of that this is just
crazy
it's just weird but it had here in
flavor which which took some time to get
it took you know until maybe episode it
was specifically and add a flavor and it
was at the time you know I didn't really
like I thought it was alright but when
it when we stopped doing it and now with
all the messages we got it was like more
messages and I got then like any other
type of series or anything that I did
people were just like hey you took
something away that I look forward to
all the time and it was unique and it
was this and my only thing is like now I
I totally get I have a lot of nostalgia
even though it's very recent for the
show and like sometimes I'll go back and
watch the last episode because it's kind
of like there's an intro touching moment
in the end where we're all just kind of
like hugging it out and
it was good it's like Breaking Bad they
just we we did it for a little bit it
was a thing that was gone we took it
away yeah you were here on top but it's
just funny and better but based on the
performance of it you don't have as much
incentive to go back to that as
California on or I would love to do and
we talked about trying to work it into
some sort of podcasts I've been toying
around with a lot of things but a
podcast was something I've wanted to do
early early early before podcast took
off and the ask Assam thing kind of
happened and then it ended I was like
well it'd be cool that turning it take
it and evolve it into something else
but it really hinged on my animator who
was a great animator he did all the you
know animated moving heads and although
for Miss John he's the guy know this is
a guy named Dan Fletcher who's super
great he turned that stuff or we shoot
it on a Monday morning and he would have
a cut ready by like Tuesday night and he
would it would go out Wednesday mornings
crazy so it was like once once he
realized how much work it was and he
started getting other job offers he just
got a another job getting paid somewhere
else which more than what we were paying
him and I was like I can't afford to pay
more you know we can't afford to pay
more and I was kind of like waffling on
the whole idea anyway so it's like all
right we'll just we'll just call it here
but we're gonna I do still feel like I'm
missing a whole you know piece of
engagement because I do like even though
the comments if they were you know like
mean or funny or whatever they were I
enjoyed the engagement being able to to
do that I don't like to be this kind of
like transient youtuber who just goes
away and comes back every once in a
while that was cool cuz it kept me there
weekly and that's why I thought of like
a podcast or something or some sort of
evolve as cast and is still interesting
to me but but I felt like that that that
ask Kassim was kind of the evidence that
you kind of wanted to do things on
YouTube on your own terms
mm-hmm you know I we always thought you
were funny respected you and called you
a comedian not a youtuber you know so
based on the creative decisions you
would make and the things you would do
in the things you wouldn't do
did you see that yourself I mean is that
how you would approach things well
typically they would just yeah I would
just vlog or I would do what other
youtubers are doing but right I did that
yeah I mean I I feel like I did all the
standard stuff early YouTube days like
during the YouTube live days you know
and I didn't go to seven eight nine but
it was around you know that whole time
it's like either you were just a vlogger
or you did something else but you know
vlogging was an easy way in and I did it
and I just felt so like it felt kind of
gross to me I mean I have the utmost
respect for people that do it daily but
I didn't like having people peer into
that side of my life it's a personal
thing and so he does it and it's great
because I watch Shay's vlogs I don't
watch a lot of YouTube videos but I i
watch Shay's vlogs cuz they're it's like
watching your family that you know and I
and even though I do know them I feel
like that's what how the audience sees
it so it was more of a privacy thing
than it was a crime a standard thing
yeah it was it was a privacy thing and
the comedic standard thing is definitely
a part of it because there was it's hard
to you like to craft and take time with
jokes not just turn on a camera and just
upload whatever there is it seemed
easier to me well yeah cause it's the
you know the complete opposite of
stand-up which is a thing that is honed
over time and right you developed and
and every beat is in because in place
and then you'd say I'm just gonna sort
of just throw up my thoughts here and
edit yeah together that's what makes you
know at the same time that's why the
most successful youtubers do that stuff
but I just think I made an early
decision to not include that stuff and
it had to do like at the time I was
going through a breakup and it was like
all these things seemed to just not work
for me at the time but and I'm kind of
glad I tried it you know I can
understand what it's like to have to
turn on a camera and then like make
something happen or just I get it and
it's not easy and I don't want to
diminish vlogging in any way I just it's
not my style of content and it's it's
hard for me to do it's much harder for
me like Shay I could turn the camera on
and Shay will be bouncing off the walls
and something will happen his kid will
hit the ceiling you know and I just I'll
sit there and I'll just think of
thing weird and I feel like more people
would be kind of put off by me if they
got inside my head you know I never know
yeah never know we we want to come back
to you and YouTube and just yeah be to
your entire story but I know in the time
that you haven't been making as many
videos you've been doing a lot of
interesting things including yeah
driving in the Baja 1000 oh yeah yeah I
did because you came here when we shot
the what women want music video yeah
we're driving this like Baja out truck
yeah I you know I grew up in Southern
California for the most part I've been
here since 93 so that the whole off-road
Motorsports world kind of sunk in to me
when I was like in high school and yeah
like to me my first two vehicles were
trucks and I still have my my Toyota
Tacoma which I did some work to because
I enjoyed off-roading and it's not that
slow rock crawly type stuff that you'll
see you know yeah on the East Coast out
here we do fast you know sort of through
the desert jump off dunes type
off-roading get some air you get some
air yeah that's the most fun getting all
four tires off the ground but so what
happened with the Baja 1000 long story
short is I was shooting and this is like
the most epic just to give people the
definition yeah we went to the Baja 500
oh you want one time yeah I'll tell you
more about that but so the 1000 is twice
that it's out of Ensenada Mexico and
you're going down the Baja Peninsula
hoppin dice 1000 miles this last was
1275 so it was ferments not a little
apause and anybody and how long does
that take for the winner I mean the
winners are doing like the four wheel
class yeah the winners are doing it in
like less than a day I forget what the
winning times where I want to see like
like in a Tina or 20 hours no these guys
are running like the guys that finished
first are running like there's the
unlimited class there's a trophy truck
class looked like desert monster trucks
they are I mean anybody can enter like
you could enter in like I was the same
entrance fee or every every
a category of racers every what do you
call it group it's the same interest fee
and it's the same prize money at the end
which is like I don't know four thousand
bucks or a thousand bucks oh but nobody
you know you get these teams that are
sponsored by multi-million dollar
companies and their trucks or you know
the race trucks worth almost a million
but and then they have like three or
four chase trucks that are all like a
fuel grain I mean there's there's a lot
of helicopters that follow them I mean
there's so much money in it my problem
is it like there's no one really doing a
good job of televising the sport
because I watched a documentary when I
was younger called dust of glory and
it's a documentary on the Baja 1000 and
I thought it captured the whole
spectacle perfectly like it's a holiday
for the Mexicans down there kids are out
of school the trucks are lined up on the
street for contingency you can just go
up and talk to the drivers take pictures
where they get in the trucks and I think
that's so cool and when I was finally
down there to see it it was just it was
mind-boggling it literally is like
Christmas down there for everyone
there's no school there's uh there's
nothing but like Bros and raced like in
race shirts and black billed hats
cruising around and black socks and it's
kind of a free-for-all like the stories
we would hear from drivers was you'll be
going over a hill and then some Mexicans
will have created a homemade newbie trap
like be trapped dragging like booby
traps were part of the risk dry up
dragging a mattress out so when you land
you're laying it on a mattress it's the
the spectators down there are both
really fun and can be really scary
because if you're doing a hundred miles
an hour and you hit a jump and you can't
see what's on the other side of it there
may be a kid or a counter said somebody
dies almost every year I feel like and
they stir so close the spectators are so
close you could just if they stuck their
hand out yeah that's the thing we
couldn't believe was we were actually we
had access to the big river ditch thing
there in Ensenada at the start yeah
right where everybody's pictures lined
up against there because we cuz this was
like oh eight I guess with Cadillac hum
hum hum er yeah yeah Hummer oh yeah I
remember that truck and so we got to
like be with rod Hall's team
and I remember so many people just lined
up there and these trucks coming through
there and just spinning I was like if
they lost control they would just roll
right into this crowd of oh well the
first like the race started four or five
trucks in it's coming down to go into
the ditch down that embankment and it
just rolls over into a group of people
and right so you would think like oh my
god the horror but they all scattered
and then after they realized nobody was
killed the entire place just cheered I'm
like oh my god this is awesome up to you
let's go back to the beginning of Kassem
G the human being not the comedian being
so where you from where's you where your
parents from well I'm getting
nationality yeah I was born in Jordan in
83 to a Jordanian father and a Egyptian
mother and I didn't ever live in Jordan
I was just born there and it maybe
stayed there for like two three months
and then as a family we all moved to
Saudi Arabia so I spent the first four
years of my life living in a compound in
Saudi Arabia you but you don't remember
any of that I do remember a little bit I
remember my last my fourth birthday
party just because there was like a huge
Mickey Mouse cake and like what do you
mean a compound compound is like in in
Saudi Arabia there's a lot of people
that go there for work and they don't
necessarily have to be middle-eastern
they could be white people on business
but they build these sort of like
concrete neighborhoods that are walled
off yeah and there's you know one
entrance one exit sort of thing and it's
safer and that's where we live and there
were other Middle Eastern people there
were white people that live there my dad
worked in the hotel biz so yeah a lot of
the business people worked there and we
lived there for until 87 and moved to
Florida because my dad got a promotion
and was offered a visa so he worked for
the hotel in Florida yeah so we he got
his ability to leave the country because
when you're in those countries you can't
leave unless an American company offers
you a job in America so you can get a
working visa or you marry somebody
that's an American
so there's really not a whole lot of
options which I realized last year when
I went back to Jordan which is it's a
different story but he got his visa and
we moved to Florida and we did six years
in Florida think of it like a prison
sentence so took ten years old Florida
that's where everybody you know brother
was born
now the weird stuff happens all the
world news stories come where the worst
stuff happens in the world but what is
it like being eight nine ten years old
in school this jordanian egyptian kid it
was very weird
i was what part was hard are we talking
and oh okay
but Kissimmee which is much worse it's
where we go to playlist you know we put
you up in those right it's like right
next to all the attractions so it's a
tourist town yeah but it was right next
to the Marriott World Trade Center where
my dad worked so he had a little short
5-minute drive there what was your
question was it was it a pleasant place
for you to be not an outsider no I had I
think it happened more when I moved to
California but I was as a kid I was very
self-conscious of being a foreigner in a
in America and you know I might have had
a little accident when I came here and I
I didn't do things right like raise my
hand the correct way or like you know
little things that you get corrected on
but all you want to do is just
assimilate and fit in and not stand out
as a kid from another country living in
this country and I have a thing that I'm
writing which hopefully will shed a
whole bunch of light on this stuff but
it was kind of hard mail it's a it's
it's a show it's a TV show which it has
like flashbacks of me as a kid and there
was but it takes place when I moved to
California and I was like ten trying
good kind of like the Wonder Years
because that was my favorite show and I
think part of the reason I screwed I
just was so weird cuz I did watch The
Wonder Years and I thought that's how
families were supposed to be acting you
know like like Wayne the Big Brother
treating Kevin like s-sorry I know you
believed the show you you were I never
watched one of yours but you were
obsessed with it very much
fried it like every episode oh there was
a lot of cool the next day and you're
like yeah Paul and Kevin really
connected like right and I was treating
my brother like crap because that a
younger brother so I was like I gotta be
like Wayne and hit my brother around and
walk him out it was you know out of
everything so there was one specific
okay so that's that's Florida we lived
there till 87 I go to Montessori School
in part of public elementary school
there my brother's born
dad gets another job now it's in
California so it's 93 ok we leave
Florida which just had Hurricane Andrew
and then we come to California and then
a few months later we have the
earthquake 94 earthquake so we thought
we brought a lot of bad luck but kind of
93 in Southern California is where like
most of the story picks up you know
going to school 5th and 6th grad started
in fifth grade so I did most of
elementary school middle school and high
school all out here and you know just to
kind of piggyback on what you're saying
about how I felt now felt very alienated
is a story I tell that kind of sums it
up pretty well when I moved to
California started a new school it's one
of the first days of school right and I
didn't have any friends and I was just
kind of like a wandering dude just like
that weird guy at the party at parties
that hangs in the kitchen just waiting
for people to talk to him sort of I was
that guy and one afternoon after lunch
our teacher said ok we're gonna do an
activity in the quad and in the quad
there was a painted mural of the United
States right with all the states of all
outlined and bordered and everything ok
I said all K kids you guys go stand on
the state you were born and it'll be
real fun
it'll be a real fun to see and so like
all the kitchen is nothing through that
one couple kids walked over to like
where New York might be or was as most
of the kids were huddled around Southern
California saw some weird kid from
Washington and then you would look over
and I was standing in a plane or maybe
50 yards away because that's where I
thought I would be relatively United
States and and I wasn't trying to be
funny I was just like I'm not from that
mural I don't
I'm from the planner right and so I'm
feeling super I'm it's like me and then
the rest of the class right and they're
all looking at me because the teachers
like what are you doing I was like I'm
born in Jordan it might be over here
somewhere and I look over and there's
another kid who's kind of close to me is
his name is Craig normal white kid
blended in perfectly god bless him and
he was kind of staying by me and I was
like where were you born E is like Saudi
Arabia like my dad was on business so we
were thinking the same thing I went from
feeling like the most alienated person
in the world more alone than I have ever
you know and then looking over and
seeing like others abutters a buddy but
who knows what it's like there's a white
dude here plane flight is so that was
it's moments like that that kind of
shaped me as a kid there's endless
moments like that but it was it was
weird it's more weird for me as an adult
to look back at it because when you're a
kid you're just going through it and
you're like even when I was 20 and 22
it's like I was just a kid who cares you
know but as you get older then you sing
especially when you hit like 30 and you
start asking yourself like Who am I why
am I here and you start to reflect on a
lot of that stuff and for a while I was
like angry with my parents for not like
instilling culture and me but they did
you know then then you're like feeling
great for your parents because I got a
chance to go back to Jordan and see how
hard it was for my family or my dad to
leave and was that his whole trip
well my grandma got sick last year and
since I had never been back to Jordan
since I was there for that first three
months and they had been asking me to
come and I just was like and I got my
own thing going I was always younger in
school or something but mmm when my
grandma got sick last year around April
it was like a very last-minute thing me
and my brother just got back from Hawaii
visiting my folks and then three days
later me and my dad my mom my brother
all on a plane to Jordan to go see my
sick grandma and it was also like you
know meeting your cousin I had I have
one cousin that lives in the United
States that I talked to his name's
Michele and he's you know he lived with
us when we were younger and he's like a
brother to me and my brother but other
than that I don't know
the other family members really so I got
to go back and meet cousins and cousins
and cousins and grandparents and people
that all share your own blood that
you've never seen before which and then
you talk to them and you find out what
their lives are like and you're like
well my my ass is not as bad as what
these guys are going through right now
or it's just very different and I'm very
lucky to be where I'm at it was it was
good and I had a lot of respect for my
my mom and specially my dad for making
that that leap now you said that there
was a time that you you had some
resentment toward your parents because
they didn't instill enough of your
heritage so maybe when I was like 25 or
something you know just when you start
to like you know your car insurance
rates get lower and then you start
thinking more inwardly about yourself
and realizing you probably have a ton of
emotional problems that you've never
dealt with you know that's I had for a
while and it wasn't a long time but I
got no fight with my parents for not
instilling more of the culture in me but
they did they they did and they
continued to and they never turn their
back on their culture they just had to
do certain things to like for example
like the day after 9/11 we bought an
American flag right now I was like why
do we have to do this it's like I was
upset about that later like why'd you
guys have to do that I mean we I know
you were just trying to blend in but
that's just what being in this country
is about you you support the country
that you live in and you're proud of
where you came from and they did their
best but I didn't think that for a long
time that was just my ignorance you know
my parents worked really hard to get us
here I mean my brother so did you deal I
mean I know a lot of kids who whose
parents are from another place kind of
deal with that embarrassment of their
parents oh yes they did drop us off like
a mile away from school or we would walk
you know there was no way I didn't
invite him to parent-teacher night or
the PTA open house like they would
mysteriously never get those invites I
was embarrassed I really I really was it
was it was uh not it just made
me stand out more than I needed to
because in my in my in my world at that
time as a 16 15 year old I just needed
to be playing the game just socially
just be normal be a regular dude don't
be that weird foreign guy you know whose
mom cooks weird things and like she
would she'd cook weird things in the
smell would get on my sweatshirt and I'd
like wash my clothes a lot just to make
sure I wasn't snob to have people check
me and like always smelling myself and
it's it does a lot of wing bringing
weird foods to lunch
you know like who you know it's like I
showed people for the first time what
pita bread was I think right during its
solar for pita was yeah it was awkward
at the time and now get maker studios if
you'd had gotten in on that one here I
should have was your ticket yeah it was
it was hard but I am so grateful for the
fact that I had to go through it a
little bit differently than a lot of
people I know because I think it made me
who I am and it made me you know I was
very defensive and I didn't like being
made fun of so I had to develop some
sort of like quick wit cuz it was the
only thing I had so that was the I was
17 development of the comedy was the
coping Megan right I had to keep
people's attention off of like my either
glasses my nose my crooked teeth or my
acne with some other method and what was
your your biggest venue a wisecrack here
and there or did you find a larger
audience at a young age I think I was I
was very much the class clown but I
think I remember specifically in sixth
grade I was in a I was in drama in sixth
grade and the first show I improvised a
thing where I hit somebody in a butt
with a giant mallet like a rubber mallet
I'm laughing right now and I've eyes it
was like someone in the butt yeah
exactly I thought it was such a cool
move you know go off script but I got a
huge laugh a huge laugh and I'm thinking
about it now so dumb
but it was it was like crack I guess it
was it was like oh yeah yeah yeah all
right okay all right I'm buying mallets
now buying big rubber mouse but yeah I
didn't do I think I wanted to do drama
in high school and things like that but
I was too
worried about my social order to to risk
being labeled as a drama person yeah so
I I experienced that stuff and like call
it the Community College it was like the
first time I ever you know decided to do
it seriously and take some classes and
then I took some formal classes actually
just down the street from you guys I
just passed it and had all these
terrible flashback memories of my old
acting school on the way here which
which one was it
I don't want to jam I don't want to drop
him I don't want to drop them because
they weren't that great but I did meet a
lot of cool people in there and there
was some good teachers there but I
wouldn't recommend it Oh in a place so
you said that you're mining your
experiences as a kid for a show yeah but
I don't need to right yeah you don't
want to talk about it because it I don't
lie don't not the type of guy that
because it may not ever happen but I am
trying to write a TV show that deals
with my experiences as a kid and and
specifically you know like when I moved
here and so it's work it's like you want
to do this it's on spec kind of a thing
it's not you yeah it's not something
that's bought that we're gonna see no no
no this is something that you're I know
I'm hoping to get a pilot written and
then go pitch it and it'll be made it
just it depends on who wants to make it
now and I'm in this place where I want
to do things that are like that mean
that means something and they're like
stuff I would show could show my parents
and it would be like it would be good
you know as much as I loved doing
California and all those things that
there's only so much of those you can do
before you want to try and do something
bigger and then I'm also like seven
years older than when I first started
eight years old or doing YouTube videos
so but your sensibilities change right
and what you think is good changes so
yeah I'm gonna try and do something
that's not just so forgettable like well
let's let's connect the dots and then
come back to that it kind of moved
through the the YouTube story so
Community College you're doing a little
your yeah taking some classes that I was
taking improv I was doing when you get
into the stand-up thing it
you're living on our accounting I was
living in in Ventura County and driving
I was working at Best Buy full-time and
then taking acting classes after I would
get off my shifts
what were you an expert in and said Best
Buy I'm a I'm a home theater guy oh yeah
well that's am I loved speakers I love
sound and five-point-one it up sure man
you know five seven point one these at
seven point two get ten point four you
don't still work there do you no no
sometimes I'll go back into Best Buy and
just like cry you know just like buy the
office chairs and remember the pain that
I suffered there well at least you
weren't at Circuit City right well your
I have no place to go back to you're
right but either way both those stores
are screwed yeah right so yeah I was
working at Best Buy I was taking acting
formal acting classes in North Hollywood
doing a strictly comedy it was I did
stand-up well I was doing Stan I should
back up I was doing stand-up an improv
before I decided to do formal acting
classes like we're out paid money to
these so yeah i was i was doing improv
and then my improv teacher Community
College got by the name of john laprise
super nice guy was an actor himself and
really saw whatever I thought I had he
saw it too and he he took extra special
took extra special time with me and like
talked to me and and told me to do
stand-up and he was the first person I
did stand up in front of and was the
reason why I went out and did open mics
and things like that and but all this
stuff kind of happens around the same
time so forgive me if the details are a
little hazy but I was doing stand-up on
the weekends take and then I start I
decided I would also strengthen my
acting muscle which still needs a ton of
strengthening but I was gonna learn it
and and try and work on it so I was
taking classes and then by this time I
went down to part-time at BestBuy
because I knew that I was this was like
a the train was going to stop soon and I
needed to get out and figure out where I
was going
Oh at Best Buy before I actually quit
and before I went to part-time I hired
the gentleman by the name of Cory mr.
safety Williams and then said that on
his resume yeah it said mr. Snell I
don't know what it's actually didn't
even see his resume some guys like yeah
some guys here want needs a job it looks
like a nice dude and I was like all
right and I interviewed him and he told
me in the interview that he moved from
Modesto because he had a viral cat video
that was huge
you know I saw it I said like I don't
know a hundred thousand views at the
time I feel what was a lot back you you
had already seen it or you went and saw
it after no no I saw it after okay I
think he maybe even showed it to me then
I don't know he had a newspaper clipping
of him from the Modesto which was funny
it's very Cory yes yeah and we got to
know Cory yeah we yeah that makes and I
wouldn't know you guys if it wasn't for
for Cory either so right god bless him
so Cory got hired and he was telling me
that there's this and at this time I was
putting stand-up clips on YouTube I had
a youtube account but it wasn't under
cast and G I would just take I would
take my sets and then what put what I
thought were funny jokes which they
weren't but I'd put them on I'm like oh
yeah this is what this is the future you
just put these clips online and then
they'll and then people will love get
the big hits right and then nobody
watched him and it I didn't understand
anything about the community but Corey's
like there's a whole group of people
that like want content but you got to
like talk to him and you got to like you
know get in and he showed me like it was
like YouTube meetups and there's these
things and he pretty much held my hand
as in the very beginning yeah he went as
one of the one of the top comedic
youtubers who also had a cat who in the
cat's own right was a top youtuber the
cat the cat definitely I don't know when
it happened but there was have been a
time where the cat was bigger than that
all of us probably so cool I mean Cory
was gung-ho Cory was so nice he is
gung-ho in life he's gung-ho in life but
he in and he applied all of that to
youtube but he was a Salesman too you
got yeah great salesman he's like you
gotta invest buy but also for you to get
on YouTube
why so one specific thing he was like
alright I'm gonna put you in a video
we'll shoot her in your lunch break
right and I was like okay whatever
and I'll upload it later tonight and I
was like whatever okay when we shot this
thing kind of like in the truck
receiving area and back and and I don't
know what it was it was pretty dumb I
was like holding a stereo that he broke
and he uploaded it and then like the
next day it had like I don't know how
many thousands of views but I was I went
and did stand-up that night at a local
Chinese restaurant and there were no
though and there were and there was no
one there to see me there was the only
people there were like finishing their
chow mein and their orange chicken and
they were probably gonna leave soon but
it was not a room built for comedy in
anyone really they had to move a piano
like into the corner and there was I was
doing stand-up and it was fine or
whatever but there was six people there
and I went home and looked on this video
and there were like Sal whatever if many
thousands of views on this one video and
I was like what what's what am I not
doing right here you know there's all
these eyeballs here people craving this
stuff here and I'm talking to a effing
wall in this Chinese restaurant so that
was it important I remember that
specifically as a moment where I decided
I think I would try and crack some sort
of you know trying to make some format
or make youtube videos and I from then
it's kind of a blur because you get
swept up in all the YouTube meet and
greets right and then you collab which
is oh man you got a collab when you
first start and the fact that you guys
asked me to be in fat dip and I was on
the moon oh I'm gonna be in fact if I
just Dean's in it and we're we made up
our minds that okay we're coming out to
LA to shoot this thing there's a good
number of youtubers out there
we're gonna reach out to everybody we
know Cory was involved making his own
videos how I the Cory part of a sanyo
yes Danny
yeah campaigner first one yes it came
out with a second one the second
campaign and we ended up I make made
videos for it oh yeah yeah and that's
what's that that money started a seeded
maker that's how we started right our
company cuz it wasn't long after that
that it was a second now so yeah so we
got everydays as i like to call him
I'll tell you from our perspective so
we're just asking everyone we know and
we told Cory to ask everyone he knew so
I think that's probably how you showed
up yeah I'll just be honest to say you
didn't know no you were calling I didn't
expect anyone to know who I was I was
like just happy to be there cuz I you
know it felt like I was like oh this is
happening man
rhett and Link we went around the pool
we're like giving the speech everybody
there only
okay here's Qasim what do you want him
to do and then it was our first meeting
huh and then you turn around and you
pull your pants down and you have on a
g-string so then we proceeded to put you
in the most clothes of anyone in the
entire video yeah so I had this lights
no just no boarding jacket that I flew
from North Carolina with cuzzo be funny
yeah and this is a Tom Petty's house yes
old house on Petty's oh the memories we
had there so you got a good shot you you
popping in the pool with the most very
good shot very boy a g-string you had on
pants you know those days when you can
like just count your subscribers coming
in yeah you know after you collab it's
like you don't leave the computer for a
while yeah it was it was like crack you
know you just wanted a collab in collab
in collab in collab in collab you hadn't
done a California on it no no so like I
got to know so throughout all the
YouTube meetups right I met Shay I met
Phil I met Shane I met you guys I mean
there's a whole bunch of people and we
just me Shay and Phil got along pretty
well and we us three hung out it was
more like Shay and Phil were buds you
know and I was still just kind of like a
no one I knew I was funny but it was
just like all right you know this I'm
still cutting my teeth getting my lumps
and by that time I had let's see quit
Best Buy but I transferred to a Magnolia
audio-video store so I still had I was
still selling TVs but now it wasn't in
fun Best Buy it was in dreary Magnolia
audio-video
which is a standalone store owned by
best BIOS right on Wilshire and Santa
Monica because I moved I moved from
Ventura County to Santa Monica so I
could audition because I was I had a
commercial agent I thought I was gonna
like being a bunch of commercials and
and I needed to be close because I
couldn't drive an hour and a half two
hours at a drop of a hat for an audition
it was too far so I moved to Santa
Monica and the station forms yeah I mean
that happened kind of a little bit after
that almost exactly after that that
second San Jose act ii campaign where we
all had to do the same thing except just
like i was a new camera this time i
don't know what it was right you guys
did it too right
we didn't okay so the second one was
like one of the first times i actually
got paid to do a video the first time
was when i did a collab with Lisa and
Shay for a crank to movie that was her
first collab but the actual one where we
got paid I think we got paid 30k total
for all of us and we just we just said
okay well we'll put that money back into
let's start this studio where we because
some of us could write some of us could
shoot some of us could edit but no one
really could do it all together and then
the idea of the studio was just to have
a place where we could pool resources
and share resources control education
because it was Lisa's house at that
moment yeah we're all just working out
of Danny's backyard right and you and
Lisa was editing the and Danny was
editing the videos and it was a it was a
waste of time because they needed to be
doing other things so if we could bring
in like an editor and like hire a guy to
shoot and maybe rent a space where we
could keep this stuff you know it would
give us a place to talk ideas we'll put
up a green screen in a room where we
want to shoot and it was very much just
that in the beginning mm-hmm and then
and then I think I did California on was
the first time so this way you had a
page over the time I still had a day job
and that was coming to a very quick end
when I made one phone call I was I
thought I and Phil has a new show
and I thought Phil has this new show I
can easily go to the beach Venice Beach
do a man on the street cut together like
a quick segment and then have them use
it in the video kind of like a throw to
field record swanda correspondent right
so I I texted Phil which was ok friends
with at the time I was ok if you want I
can it's no pressure like I've never
been the guy to say hey put me in or
like hey when are you gonna put me in
that's not my style but I did call him I
was like hey if you want I can go shoot
some today for your new show that you're
putting up tomorrow just tell me if you
have any ideas of stories that you're
gonna talk about and he was he was doing
a story on Miss California
some like racy photos that got leaked so
I took it I took my roommate Alex I
called in sick to work I didn't go
because out by that time I was I hated
every second I was in that place I
called in sick said I'm gonna go do this
and I took my Khaybar Corey's camera the
one that he shot me and Kitty on I took
that camera gave it to my roommate who
doesn't know how to use cameras realize
we didn't have a microphone we stopped
by a Radio Shack on our way down to the
beach bought a corded RadioShack
microphone with two short of a cord so
we can never get a wide enough shot and
then when we got down to the beach it
was super sunny and my roommate Alex
doesn't know how to expose a camera so
the whole video is blown out yeah and
she looks like an effect you can kind of
see me and you can kind of see me
talking to people and you can hear it
fine but I just didn't know how to fix I
didn't know how to do that stuff and I
didn't know how to edit I knew very
little but I knew I could just take
clips of this interview and smush them
together and make something that's short
right it turns out none of that mattered
what mattered was I shocked you had
balls too to say the things you were
saying these people to you got good
things out of people but you were in
character yeah seemed like and it wasn't
fun it's not like there was much of an
evolution either if you look at
California on in success even most
recent ones it's not much different I
mean yeah it's a little it's less
malicious because I I was quick to
realize that I should
not make fun of the people on the
boardwalk because I'm here every day and
this is where I live and I would rather
be a part of the fabric than tearing it
up so I kind of switched my attention
after like the second one because there
was an incident with a homeless guy that
I made fun of and I felt really bad
about and his family to know he was
homeless
and they saw the video and then they
found out he was homeless mm-hmm and how
did you find that came up to me the next
time I was on the beach he's like hey my
what's the deal my family knows I'm
homeless you're ruining my life and I
was I felt really bad and then I like
for some reason just gave him ten bucks
out of my pocket and he said thanks and
walked away he took my ten bucks that
guess we're even
but I really had to like think about
what I was doing out there instead of
trying to get the easy laugh there's
another way to do it where you can still
get the laugh and not be so mean so I
think there is a slight I mean it's not
a dramatic but there you now the
Californians versus when I first started
I I don't tend to only make fun of
tourists and people that are just
passing and going young kids you know
stuff like that that are happy with it
but stayed away from making the locals
in Venice look a certain way because
that's not what I was there to do and
and I love that and I think Venice is
one of my favorite places in the world
and and and I feel like more people came
to visit Venice once they saw those
videos because there's that wall that I
always shoot Infernus it's in kind of a
pompous thing to say but people would
would always want to come down and see
where my filming spot was and I figured
I had some sort of responsibility to not
be a dick yeah because everyone because
everybody you quickly discovered it is a
community it is a community if you keep
stepping in there you're gonna right
there recognized and and they were nice
and they let me slide in it you know
couples early screw-ups but then this
surah hole prankster thing happened and
people started coming to shoot videos in
Venice that were not in good you know
they weren't in good spirits and there
were little malicious and I felt like I
had to kind of maybe
take a step back there wasn't liking
where all that was going people on the
boardwalk would associate me with
pranksters and when you saw the Sam
pepper video like the pinnacle of this
the controversy yeah what was you what
was your I was like did you react you
know you could say what you want about
the content I just felt like it was it
was not it was not the type of stuff
that I would be into her liked to watch
and I feel like I don't know who would
begin to watching this sort of thing and
it felt like it was giving the the area
bad name because it wasn't just Sam
pepper I mean there was there's other
people that just came and went and and I
don't I don't have like I don't own the
boardwalk but I just if I see something
I don't like I would rather just be like
f it I'll just step back you know and
like let these guys run themselves in
the ground I I didn't want to contribute
to any of that in any way so I think
that would come as a surprise too unless
you've shared this with the people that
one of the reasons that you you know
lowered the frequency of those videos
had to do with the way this it's a small
reason that the way that it was kind of
infiltrated by these other guys I mean
you know timing was a thing you know and
then I was up in my own head about how
to change the show cuz it's fine and I'm
glad people appreciate it and when when
every day I read a tweet that's like did
you die where's the thing how come you
don't make videos you're such a deadbeat
I know that's just people saying like we
miss your videos just make more and
that's fine I get that comes from a good
place but I I didn't feel like that show
was in a spot to just keep going and I
still will make them and but I want to
make them different and I guess the
whole reason I'm here is to pimp out
this Bigfoot special but this ties in
nicely because the Bigfoot special it's
30 minutes long and it's like kind of
like a Kalyan but it turns into
something completely different and we're
real happy with it feel like there's
some heart in it and it's so it's in the
it's it's finished and it's good i J
least we just came from a final round of
notes just now and it's supposed to be
ready for to send out tomorrow and it
should be on YouTube hopefully a week
from tomorrow on your channel on my
channel and
30 minutes 30 minutes with an extra
bonus video but I felt like look I know
I've been gone for a long time and you
guys have no idea and I don't update you
about what I do but here's like you know
I've been doing a lot of stuff and
here's one of them here's a fun little
30 minute video it's the least I could
do for the viewer so there's a lot of
fun so I mean what's new about it you're
not just interviewing people on Venice
about Bigfoot for another comments are
you it's like uh no no it's not in
Venice at all it's it's my own Bigfoot
special where I go on the road to go
hunt for Bigfoot it has nothing to do
with California on it's in California
and it starts with some
man-on-the-street stuff that's
California on style got it but the rest
is more of a travel documentary me and
my road crew you've been working on this
for quite some time right yeah I mean
it's it we finished we filmed it in
August but I decided that I would a race
in the Baja 1000 I've cast and another
thing I had to shoot and then I had
decided I would do all the artwork for
this video on my own which was a bad
idea because I don't know how to do art
and things a long time what do you mean
do artwork I decided that I would have
some artwork in there some some
dramatizations some Illustrated
reenactments animation well it's
watercolor that I had somebody cheaply
animate stuff - okay and it has its so
the watercolors in in this it's not
California on Bigfoot
it's called California on sasquatch and
Finding Bigfoot special okay the virtue
of ignorance but all the watercolors
that is your work that's all my work and
it think it matches my sort of lo-fi I'm
in the arts not very good and this video
my you know I think we we had a lot of
fun making it but it's it's not like a
fancy slick video it's it's it's I think
it's a good next step for Kalyan it's
doing these things and we want to do a
ghost one and I want to do aliens and
these are things I'm kind of into and
like regular life which is a lot easier
than thinking about your own fee
wings and problems okay which I want to
find out of us I want to find out about
that because you know when I hear Kassem
G is interested in the Sasquatch the
what I think is okay he's gonna have his
day with these people who are into
Sasquatch he's screwing with everybody I
I don't screw with these people at all I
it's something that if somebody's gonna
come out and talk to me about something
that's very real to them about a
something and and when they tell you
these things are most of the time that
you can tell it's very authentic and
it's not something that they probably
talk to and a lot of people said look
I've never told anyone this because I
think people will think I'm crazy but
yeah I've seen what like I saw what it
was I didn't know what what to think of
it it was just weird and my job is to
not make fun of that my job is saying
it's at least for this video to
encourage more information because I'm
genuinely interested so where's the
comedy well the cops the comedy comes
from the absurdity of the situation that
we're in there's there's moments in
there it's it's not like it's not like
California where we try to rapid-fire
jokes there's like it there's an arc and
there's like a whole whole thing I'm
interested to see what you guys think
about it progressing it so thirty
minutes to spare there's a legitimate
search hey we are with thermal cameras
interested in this
I've always loved I mean you know
there's a Leonard Nimoy rest in peace
documentary that I watched when I was a
kid about finding you know searching for
Bigfoot and then every Bigfoot special
that's ever been out since I've watched
and digests it and I listen to Bigfoot
podcasts and sometimes I stay up in the
middle of night and read encounters on
the BFRO website and you decorate your
home with Bigfoot yeah seeing the
Instagram right I definitely went deep
and some Bigfoot merch I have a picture
of patty a cell of the Patterson footage
that's blown up but it's like framed on
my wall it's real fun I have a Bigfoot
doormat
well they say no more
and it's mostly fun but I do you know I
do hope that we sold the episode to
Samsung which is great because I wasted
a lot of money
I've always had a ton of money and
resources on this thing so what was nice
is that we did it and somebody saw some
potential and and paid for it too
and hopefully we can continue to do more
of these so what's their integration
like you're like out you're like you're
like using the light from a Samsung
there's no it's there's no product
placement at all they just get the video
for a week on their Android app before I
release it on YouTube
okay which I thought was a killer deal
you know it's it's they're gonna help
pay for the product actually almost all
the production that I spent just to have
it a week early and and if you have an
Android device you'll be able to
download and watch it and then if you
don't want to you can just wait till
it's out for free on YouTube a week
later so it's really not a bad deal at
all and I hope to be able to do more of
them I am very intrigued and I'm
certainly committed to watching it I
think you want our thoughts I'll be glad
to give them I would love to hear what
you guys think cuz I would love to get
people's thoughts that I I respect and
watch because it's different than
anything I mean it's it starts off
feeling kind of familiar like maybe a
kalyan comic-con where it's man on the
street in a different area uh-huh and
then it has a little bit of like a
reality-show vibe to it but then it's
not and it's kind of like a travel doc
and there's a little bit suspense and we
don't find Bigfoot and we're very clear
it's in the title but it's more about
just us being out there and and we were
pretty scared but yeah I want my my team
they're all my best friends and they're
also happened to be the guys that help
me make videos you know it's my brother
it's John you know and Lane and Ricky
who's in the other room I mean these are
guys I hang out with on the weekend so
if I can get into a situation where my
production team and my buds we're
getting paid to go shoot stuff that I'm
really into that would be cool and make
content that's that's like you know you
could sit down for a while and watch it
and not just digest it so quick so this
represents an evolution of California on
but to take a step back I've always been
curious about whether it's California on
or going deep or talking to cosplay
women at conventions there's is there an
element of having to psych yourself up
and how much of a character do you
assume in your own mind what tell me
about the place you've got to go to in
order to interact with people and create
these comedic moments oh it's not that
hard it's honestly I was you were
talking about this I forget with who but
I've had a lot of experience talking to
people now I did 10 years at best by
selling TVs for 10 years right so that's
like you talk your cold starting
conversation with people for 10 years
every day and then then I did man on the
street and you're cold starting
conversations with people for one over
the last 7 years or whatever it is I
don't have a problem with getting in to
a convo and I don't think I have to suck
myself up I just get so tired like if
it's a Comic Cons especially and I have
to try and like think of a soundbite
Uruk witty thing to say while there's
like you know a giant transformer
walking around there's like dubstep
blaring in your left ear and there's
like a chick with an amazing body who's
half naked over here there's so much
stimulus that if I walk around comic-con
for four hours I need to sleep for like
two days yeah it takes a lot out of me
and it's like you're just making
Internet videos dude like shut up but
it's it's not more of like I got to get
myself in the moment if I can just get
there and then that's half the battle
like reading getting there and just
turning on the camera and then once I
get a few in the bank it's fine and then
you know when you get warmed up
everything comes out better and when you
get in that zone there's like a good
three or four hour period where I'm in a
zone and then I get maybe 70% of the
footage and then if I don't get anything
I'll piece it together how wrong have
things gone I mean if you're one slug oh
yeah I got [ __ ] I mean everyone always
asked me I got slapped by some guy at
South by Southwest I think he was a
gangbanger so I'm glad it didn't
escalate any farther but I honestly I'm
I should have been attacked more than
what did you say to that guy
he was he
I don't think I forget it's in the video
it's a no so it's out of the video yeah
but I just started shouting at him and
then he slapped me and then I ran after
him with the camera on and then I tried
to make fun of him but there was a lot
of like there's my own problems coming
out I don't like I don't like when that
happens but nothing life-threatening you
know I just feel a little exposed at
Venice Beach sometimes just because I
have been doing it for a while and if
for some reason I really hated Kassem G
I could just probably hang out at the
beach for a while wait for him to get
there and they just stabbed him in the
temple you know like I definitely
thought this I'd have I went through a
good year to where I had very bad
anxiety where I had I had panic attacks
and things because it was like maybe a
year into people like saying hi to me on
the street that would recognize me from
videos which is great I love that but I
had a real issue with it just like being
noticed that was very uncomfortable with
it it came from a weird place I don't
know why I didn't like the thought of
somebody possibly knowing who I was in a
restaurant but me not knowing any of
these people and then it would be
validated by me getting a tweet from
like somebody tweeting the back of my
head at a restaurant or something so I'm
sure it's happened to you guys but at
that time I don't know a few years ago
but I had a pretty big anxiety disorder
thing that happened with it but it's
fine now
you know I don't I don't have panic
attacks anymore I did worry about
getting murdered on the beach there was
a group of skaters I think that really
wanted to beat me up for a while but you
know Richard I don't want you find out
about that
just like somebody's like there's a
group of skaters over they really want
to fight you I don't know I did I don't
know there's so much that can happen at
that Beach like I've seen people get in
fistfights I had nothing to do with it
can hang can erupt at any moment that
that place is so volatile that you know
you don't have security it can be a
scary place but the like the tattoo guys
that work right next door everyone all
the vendors were really nice and they
looked out for me which which is part of
why I was happy that I tried to you know
show Venice in a better light as opposed
to make fun of
but I think a lot of people you know on
the outside looking in might think oh
well it seems like the timing really
works out you know maker gets bought by
Disney
I know Qasim was there from the
beginning so okay he just cashed in a
little bit he doesn't have to make
videos I mean yo ya cashed in but I
would have I think the whatever happened
with my videos just like the would have
happened regardless whether or not the
Disney thing happened it we had a lot to
do with just me being unhappy with the
formats and where they were at and
wanting to do something new but yeah I
mean getting millions of dollars is also
a gives you a little bit of a buffer to
not have to worry about like I never I
was in that spot as a youtuber where
it's like oh Friday I got no videos like
what am I gonna do I got a mail it in I
never want to be in that position again
because it's cheap for the audience if
you're mailing it in it's cheap for
yourself and all it is just to kind of
feed this like never-ending monster that
I was always hungry and I don't want to
I don't want to be caught up in that I
was I feel happier
well how does losing that that sense of
desperation that I think a lot of
youtubers feel when you experience you
know when you when you when you cash in
how does that change the way you
approach your work you take your time
with it but it's hard to you know I I
have to do something that's the Bigfoot
thing was the impetus behind that was
said we got to do something new and
bigger it'll take longer I won't be
putting videos up but at least I'll be
taking a step in a direction that I want
to go is but there is it is a risk
you've put a lot in Oh I mean I've look
is there anxiety associated with doing
it the wrong way you know like if you
want to be successful like on YouTube
it's it's consistency and I just I'm not
as worried about is when I was playing
that YouTube hustle years ago it's I
have I've carved out a nice little like
audience for myself that you know I'm
happy with if the subscribers keep
coming great but like there's no way I'm
gonna play that game I couldn't even
imagine being somebody like PewDiePie or
like guys
uploading three videos a day it's
they've I've seen I've seen its take its
toll on myself and I've seen it take
tolls on other youtubers and it's no way
to live just just to feed a machine that
way and and it also like I got to do
other things you know that if I took
didn't take the time away from YouTube I
would have never got to do so I I'm
happier I get to do different things and
but ultimately like my love is just you
to like I really want to I'm not going
away I'm just gonna change what I do and
maybe it'll be less or maybe I'll find
another format and it'll hit so are you
doing going deep anymore or is that done
that hasn't been decided I just it's
another one of those things where I'm
pretty unhappy with where that where I'm
at or what I think is funny
and and I don't necessarily think that
shows is funny now is when I used to do
it early on I mean how do you give me in
looking back at it how do you feel about
it I'm happy I'm happy with all I mean
there's there's ones that I feel like
you know I probably crossed some sort of
line and there's probably a lot of
moments like that and I feel like I made
those at the maturity level I was at
when that happened but if I was to do it
now it would definitely have a different
feel more like a kalyan is changing I
would change going deep to be less going
deep ish I don't know and I know a lot
of people get bummed out about that
because they like the show in what way
what are you going deep ish what do you
mean it's just like I don't know it's
like guy talking to a porn star for
laughs you know it's fine I think it's
it wasn't like there's Mo's real funny
moments and one of my favorite videos is
the aw Sakura one because it just I
don't talk to them at all before and and
I just let it go and then sometimes
really fun stuff happens like the Aussie
Kara one and then other times I can't
air the episode because they the Heather
manager call and say that you know there
that's not gonna air so you were
certainly in character but there's no
prep whenever you're talking to a porn
star
no there's prep it's it's half written
half
I shoot for like an hour and a half
maybe a hour and 45 they don't meet you
until he sit down no no no I actually
will do like I used to do things like
yell at my crew before I I stepped it I
wanted to create a sort of environment
of like where they thought I was a huge
huge [ __ ] yeah
and I would like yell at the person
putting my mic on why are you doing it
this way taken too long and if they
didn't have something ready for me I'd
blow up about it and I would I wouldn't
look at them or talk to them until the
camera was rolling and sometimes they
would just be looking at me like
wondering when I'm gonna acknowledge
them which is great cuz some those
moments are real to me and they're
they're not they're not forced and it's
it's real awkwardness which is great I
don't see especially these prank videos
like half of them 80% of them are staged
like why why are we watching these
there's no real reaction here there's no
human emotion being displayed there's
there's nothing there's nothing risky
about it but when we sit down and do
those interviews like I don't know
what's gonna happen in there and there's
like there's two or three interviews
that I haven't aired because of the
person not wanting them to air and had
you met porn stars in person off camera
before what a porn star might be as
people maybe at conventions or something
like that as people porn stars like your
experience interviewing College all the
girls most of the girls I chatted with
really nice right very nice people can
seemed really lovable and fun and like
oh they're cool when they don't do porn
but some of them are I would have to say
most of them are that way because of
some sort of like trauma and like some
crazy thing that happened in their lives
like they're not they're broken people
for the most part and not every one of
them
they're people think that y'all hang out
with porn stars has got to be the
coolest thing like it's super depressing
there's a lot of like there's a lot of
drug use there's alcoholism there's like
domestic violence there's there's a
whole slew of problems with the porn
industry
that I I don't really agree with you
know and and and it's that part of it
because it seems like I mean I would
have assumed that after the initial
success of going deep that people would
be contacting you so that you could
break these girls off show I have people
contacting me still but they're not
people I want on the show Riley have
certain I I have I will say I will do
another one if there is one thing I've
been trying to find which is a couple
that where they both do porn but the
male does gay for pay porn and if
somebody can step out that I will do
that so it's gonna take what you heard
it here yeah that's good but otherwise
it's like you know it's repetitive I
didn't want to keep doing I and a lot of
the porn stars that reach out to you are
just you know they are just looking for
some sort of just anything sort of
attention whether you know like oh it's
fine they'll make fun of me but I'll get
a bunch more followers and I like to
think of that shows like I'm
taste-making
I'll pick the porn stars myself you know
because in the comments it's like hey I
just looked her up after this video and
I'm a big fan now as I like to feel like
I have some influence over who people a
jerk to so well I would assume that
people when you lose the you lost your
cover a little bit you know you got
these girls coming in and now they know
oh I talked to her yeah
the last you know it's few they're like
they're acting at that point they have
to you know my I make sure my producers
town look he it's an act but he's not
gonna talk to he's not gonna be nice to
you after he'll be super nice and I am
like after the interviews are done I'll
go and try and be like that was really
funny I know there's that you probably
think I'm an [ __ ] I'm just that's
just that way for the camera but it I I
have no need to go back and do more
unless I think it'll be really funny I
don't
again I don't feel like I have to just
feed a machine just to feed the Machine
yeah which is that pompous I it's more
just like I want to keep the quality at
a certainty is one thing yeah and and I
think it's refreshing that I'm I'm not
playing a YouTube game you know and
collabing with people that you don't
want to see and making videos that you
know are social experiment
mm-hmm I don't know I I'm pretty happy
with where I'm at and you're I think
you're happy with me too yeah oh yes
very and in your also leave your hand
your act magically in front of our face
yeah I try to do a little bit of that
too do you actually get directed by
Michael Bay for that scene in
transformers I did yeah what was that
like uh I was fine it was a trip it
really was that being on that set is you
know I've been on a few set I've been on
two film sets but that film set was like
a film film set it was like you know
okay you're gonna be looking up at the
top of the ceiling you're in a wind
tunnel right it's like a GM wind tunnel
it's like a room that maybe 20 other
people have ever been in their life and
you got to pretend you're looking at a
transformer and meanwhile there's like a
hundred extras running around behind you
and Stanley Tucci's banging on the board
and you just have and you got my lines
that morning you know I just was told I
was gonna improvise them but I didn't
get to I just he just told me what lines
to say and they you know they came out
weird and they cut some stuff it was
fine it was a good experience but I got
that because it going deep they saw
going deep and they're like maybe we can
use that character somehow in the movie
and I ended up auditioning for like four
different things and they're like well
you didn't get any of them but they want
you in it and just you know improvise
some lines so you'll go there for five
days and see what happens so I was like
okay then I did that and it was pretty
stressful getting your lines 20 minutes
before you shoot them you know on
something that'll be there forever
yeah and yeah Michael Bay is interesting
he likes funny guys which which is cool
he's he's cool it's glad to see him work
a work asset especially if there's women
on it you know there's always beautiful
women when Michael Bay's around he's
kind of like I don't he's a nice guy
loves funny guys so how much I mean how
much do you want to do acting versus I
mean you said you're loyal to YouTube
and you're not going away
well not but I doesn't mean I can't do
other stuff and I you know I and for a
couple pilots I shot a pilot last year
I'm shooting one now but there until
they're out you know
I'll talk about him but I liked us to
work that muscle cuz it's not like
YouTube it's like somebody else gets to
do all the work and I can just kind of
focus on this one thing which is nice
and it's also a great way to get paid
like you know five days of work getting
paid on a motion picture is is great but
money just keeps coming every every day
if it comes out on DVD there's more
money okay but in the theater is pretty
nice yeah it's cool well I mean back at
the top you talked about how one of the
factors in not being not wanting to play
quote the YouTube game was just to
preserve some level of privacy and I
know being with a vlogging yeah yeah
with the vlogging but I think with the
with the content that you've created
over the years people have they have a
perception of you that you know you
don't let a lot of people in you know I
appreciate over the course of this
conversation you've been very candid and
but you don't you don't choose in a lot
of places to you know to put yourself
out there that way I like that and you
know that's just how I am I don't I keep
people around me that I trust and that I
like you know and I don't feel like I
have to change that for any reason and I
it's not because I'm guarded as just you
know i-i've old enough to where I like
certain things and can draw boundaries
with other things you know it's it's uh
I have a lot of friends but it's it's
yeah I guess I guess I'm a weirdo I
guess I'm guarded weirdo yeah I think
being guarded makes me feel weird I just
said I have a lot of friends on a
podcast which always means I don't write
so it's like I really trust me yeah yeah
truth is I don't I don't like you know
if I don't have to leave my house I
won't I got my dog and lately I've been
painting it's a very serene around my
house so it's nice so when are you gonna
start the the online gallery where
people can buy Kassem G paintings I know
a lot of guys were like hey you should
give these paintings away and I'm like
no that's just like they're not that
good I don't want to give them away
maybe I do find I do find the appeal of
like like those time lapse
pating videos you know you know watch
those yeah they're so easy to watch you
know it's like oh god I could make one
of these I'm painting right now I can I
just make one of these but they leave
people like Mary doodles to do it she's
she's great at it well it's time for you
to sign the table as we wrap up this
thing and again you know I I think we
got it we got to come back and do a part
two right one of these days yeah
Oh we'd have it what are you what are
you holding for part two well I don't
know we just talked about so much I'm
sweating bullets here and there you have
it our conversation with cast of G let
Castle know how much you enjoyed this
here biscuit is Twitter is Kassem G ka
SS EMG use hashtag ear biscuits also
remember you can really ver review on
iTunes it's very helpful and you can
join the conversation on soundcloud
that's happening over there I really
appreciate it Qasim you know what we're
friends with him and you know like you
said he's a guarded guy but you know he
came on the podcast and we can't gain a
lot of insight and who he was I think
some of you may be pleasantly surprised
that you know he's he's an actual person
he was a just a guy who has a heart who
has confrontational humor on the
sidewalks of Venice he's going he's
tapping into something there and I can
see I'll tell you right now the the
whole idea of there being a you know
some kind of sitcom or whatever that
focuses on his experiences as a kid like
this the story about standing out there
next to the potted plant or whatever
that was right I can see that working
that needs to be in front of people
right you just do it on his channel well
he must forget about television I want
to I want to plug his California on half
hour special on sasquatch again you
should because like I said at the top
when we talked to casting we hadn't seen
it and since then we have it's a lot of
fun I you know California on sasquatch
ain't not Finding Bigfoot special I
watch that on his channel so he kind of
gives it away the beginning as it was he
wasn't ended he doesn't find Bigfoot but
they
it's it's very they have fun have a lot
of fun I found it very interesting that
he approached it with a different tone
like he described to us then he does
with some of the California ons because
he you know he let all these people who
believe in Bigfoot Bigfoot speak via put
I can't speak right now but you know and
he just let him speak and it was it was
fun he wasn't trying part and wasn't
trying to make fun of them it wasn't
like hey I'm gonna ask them questions to
make them look stupid it was very much
I'm gonna I'm gonna go hang out with
these guys and we're gonna have fun we
realized that what we're doing is you
know even people who are with us like
John for instance totally thinks this is
the most ridiculous thing ever but
that's part of the humor is that he's
got this ragtag bunch of guys are going
out including hi I'm Ron being by
himself all night which i think was one
of my favorite yeah it's true so check
that out and again let Qasim know
tweeted him what you thought of his ear
biscuit will be here next week
delivering another one to your ear hall
fresh
[Music]
[Music]